également être invités pour en tant que
votre qualité de maire d'elancourt pour
évoquer la semaine du handicap dont qui
a lu dans votre commune du 2 au 10 avril
l'encours organise sa semaine dont un
handicap pour la 13e édition plusieurs
événements de sensibilisation sont
prévues toute cette semaine dans le
cadre de cette opération notamment
samedi au palais des sports de la ville
c'était la deuxième édition de la
journée andy fait en partenariat avec de
nombreuses associations venant en aide
aux personnes handicapées la ville a
proposé une après-midi de démonstration
parcours en joëlette en bike ou
badminton en fauteuil un grand nombre
d'activités étaient proposées au public
pour une journée d'échangés entre
personnes valides et personnes en
situation de handicap je vous propose
d'écouter jean marc jacquin ses
éducateurs spécialisés en prévention y
fait il était un écrou de mélanie potier
on l écoute tout de suite cessé de
montrer aux gens on valide qui qui a des
choses qui sont de possibles grâce à des
sports adaptés
parce qu'il ya quelques associations
sportives qui qui mélange les lieux
publics valides et non valides
cette semaine ça permet de remplir
certaines personnes que s'il ya des
personnes en situation de handicap et
qui peuvent vivre malgré tout avec des
choses adapté pour eux